hmm
this program was made before the
sandinistas lost the elections of
february 1990.
typically states regard the general
population as an enemy that's normal
the task and role of the population is
to be apathetic obedient passive
if it's what's called a democracy
they're supposed to show up every once
in a while to ratify elite decisions but
if they get involved in anything beyond
that they're causing trouble and they
have to be controlled
and they're an enemy in the case of one
of those newspapers
what happened is that the u.s run
security forces surrounded the office
with tanks
destroyed it drove the editor out of the
country with assassination threats after
several assassination attempts at the
caro one of them in the case of the
other one the our security forces
they're our forces remember our security
forces picked up the editor and another
journalist in a in a restaurant in san
salvador took them outside cut them to
pieces with the machete and left them in
a ditch somewhere the rest of them that
took care of the second newspaper so
there's no more problem of freedom of
the press in
el salvador meanwhile i should say in
nicaragua nothing remotely comparable
has happened the opposition claims
harassment and of course it always hits
the front pages of the newspapers but
they're not expecting to be
murdered tortured and this opposition is
extreme it's the kind of opposition
which has never survived in a western
democracy in times of crisis
la prensa for example and the groups
around it are openly support the u.s
attack against nicaragua nothing secret
about it
some people call him a radical
other people say he's just a realist
i'm referring to noam chomsky one of
america's outstanding intellectuals
we have a speech which he gave in which
he
analyzed the american mass media the
american power structure
and the american policy in central
america
and you'll be able to see it right now
on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
although this presentation by noam
chomsky was made before the san anistas
lost their elections of 1990 his
analysis and information are still
extremely important to
view and listen to because the
establishment media did not present them
today we have a videotape of a talk with
noam chomsky who is one of the top
critics of u.s foreign policy in the
media chomsky for the last 30 years has
been attacking us intervention in the
third world u.s secret covert wars and
the media is covering up of these events
in american foreign policy i first heard
chomsky talk in 1966 at columbia
university when he was the first
intellectual to really speak out against
u.s intervention in vietnam and he wrote
article after article making speech
after speech documenting u.s
intervention in vietnam the secret wars
in laos and cambodia and attacking u.s
foreign policy throughout the 70s
chomsky continued to document u.s
intervention in different parts of the
third world and of the media covering up
the u.s foreign policy crimes and
presenting legitimations of u.s
policy recently chomsky with his friend
ed herman have published a book called
manufacturing consent that talked about
how the mass media develops operates to
develop consent around u.s foreign
policy and for support of the capitalist
system and an imperialist foreign policy
through a variety of different
strategies chomsky and hermann offer
what they call a propaganda model for
the media in which they have a theory of
the different filters through which the
media filters out uncomfortable content
content that would be uncomfortable for
those that run the media those that
are involved in the u.s power structure
frank what's the first filter that
chomsky talks about well the first one
they talk about is the twin thing of
limitation of ownership for one thing
technological advances since the 19th
century started since the 20th century
started
has
have made it impossible for
and just anybody with limited capital be
able to start a mass medium it just
requires too much and then of course
when you do need capital you've got to
go to the banks and so if you can't
don't have access to the banks as
any
labor or working opposition wouldn't get
any money from banks well then you're
just out in the cold just too much
technology and too much money for
normal
working-class people or organizations to
be able to have a mass media
and that leads to the second filter
which is the advertising license to do
business chomsky points out that
in the 19th century in the united states
and in britain in most
capitalist democracies it was a very
vigorous working class press that all
the different left-wing political
parties the unions the anarchist
movement all had their press that was
very critical of the existing system the
capitalist power structure and there
were attempts
by the governments in the 19th century
to censor this left-wing press finally
they decided it was better to let the
marketplace do it one of the ways that
the marketplace worked to filter out the
left-wing press and unpopular opinions
opinions would be unpopular to the
capitalists was through advertising
supported media by making
media the press later broadcasting
dependent on advertising support this
meant that advertisers had the choice of
who they would invest their advertising
revenues in what sorts of newspapers
what sort of television and other
media so this forced the press the
broadcast media today to submit to the
needs to the ideologies
uh to the interests of the advertisers
and only to broadcast ideas that
advertisers would want to
support in fact frank there's another
sense in which both business control of
the media and advertising support of the
media and even a more direct way filters
out unpopular opinions within these
mainstream media and that is that the
big media like the television networks
have a gatekeeping function they have
managers reporters who filter out ideas
that will not be
hospitable to the owners of the press to
the power structure and the people that
control them and likewise advertisers
have ways to censor programs
general electric once
was one of the sponsors of 2020 and when
jane fonda came on who's an outspoken
opponent of nuclear energy that general
electric is deeply involved in
they refused their sponsorship so this
put a message out to 2020 and other
documentary shows but if you want to get
ge sponsoring you can't have an
anti-nuclear
point of view or advocate so this
filters out the anti-nuclear point of
view in fact general electric now owns
nbc they've completely taken over nbc is
easily the most conservative of all the
networks and that's because the
ownership
uh creates a sort of ethos within the
news and the documentary
sections of these media that the people
like tom brokaw and the others that
produced the news know that if they want
to keep their jobs they can't say
anything that g doesn't want to hear or
they're out so it's these kinds of
filters chomsky is talking about
advertising ownership that filters out
on popular opinions unpopular from their
point population
popular from our point of view
the third filter is the sources which
are used by the establishment media
the
establishment media reporters and all
they
because of economics and lack of time
and lack of number of reporters they go
to where it's easy to get news and where
you get that well from government
sources where there are leaks and there
are press conferences so you got the
state department it's easy to get stuff
from them and the pentagon and the white
house at the local level you go down to
the
local
police department to get the news
and also business corporations and trade
organizations are good sources that's
one aspect of this mass news media
sourcing
but
the media go further than that reporters
think that ipso facto
these people in government and business
are credible
because they have status and prestige
and they wear neckties those little
phallic cloth phallic symbols that show
that they're male
and so anyway
um
then the flip side of this is that they
look askance at anybody who has
different points of view either from the
lie right or from the left
they will take the words of these
establishment people
without question
because they're objective we just
reported what they said their lies
that's not our fault reagan lies we're
just reporting what he says but if
somebody say from the less or no left or
norm chomsky then well we don't know we
better check this out before we talk to
him anyway we can't find any good
reliable people from the left
so
that's why you get just a narrow
range of people and ideas coming from
the media what's the fourth filter the
fourth filter is slack and their
enforcers the media are very sensitive
to public opinion because one they
depend on high ratings
for their advertising rates they don't
want to do anything to alienate broad
sectors of the audience and secondly the
advertisers are also responsible for
public opinion or are also responsive to
public opinion because they're very
worried about boycotts of their
products they don't want to be
associated with controversial shows so
if any programming gets a lot of flack
from different right-wing groups the
networks are very worried about this as
advertisers are so the very fact of the
possibility of flat filters out
controversial opinion that might
arouse the ire of different right-wing
groups and in the 1970s and the 1980s a
lot of these right-wing groups organized
themselves to give flack in case there's
any liberal or leftist or progressive
views in the media that the right wing
doesn't like
the the organization
accuracy in media jerry falwell's
christian
groups and various other right-wing
groups
give phone calls write letters to the
media give them flack every time there's
something on there that they don't like
and it's this kind of pressure that
makes the media also
filter out controversial ideas and
particularly liberal or progressivist
ideas
the fifth filter is anti-communism
we've seen that
those of us who grew up in the mccarthy
era and all have seen this happening for
decades and how it's used for social
control
as well as how to control what's
happening in the medium because
if somebody happens to say something is
a little too liberal or left they're
soft on communism or they're promoting
the communist line
so
it helps to fragment
the left
and it also permits those right-wing
elements in
left organizations like labor unions or
what should be left organizations like
labor unions
it helps the anti-communists to be able
to take control of these and purge any
of the more progressive elements out of
it
it helps to keep opposition
politicians in line too just say oh
you're soft on communism that's enough
to make any of these lily-livered
liberals run for sure
so with all these different filters the
mass media according to chomsky
manufacture
consent to the existing
system people conform to submit to the
institutions values policies of the
established society and the media make
sure that nothing gets in that's going
to disturb this legitimacy of the system
that's going to raise questions create
problems for the managers of the system
moreover chomsky and hermann go through
a lot of case studies in which the media
manufactured consent around u.s foreign
policies in vietnam the reagan policy in
central america all of the different
ways that the media actually served the
interests of conservative policy by
manufacturing consent around these
policies of the subject matter of these
books
but there is also a problem which media
constantly have and that is they say
okay we're the watchdogs of the system
we're objective we present all points of
view
and so they have to do a little bit of
muckraking they have to bring in a
little bit of other things and you have
some reporters who are really seriously
interested in digging into some of the
skeletons and so you do find some of
these things happening in the media so
this drives the
people and the elites and the right wing
crazy but
the
as chomsky and other people have pointed
out
this still can be effective because they
don't present enough of the of opposing
points of view or enough alternatives to
the way of looking at things or doing
things
so the people really can become just
kind of confused or disoriented
rather than completely believing the
establishment line so this is functional
too
along with apathy they hope that the
populace will be apathetic
and the media have a way of doing this
also
now let's turn to noam chomsky and get
his
views on the american power structure
the mass media and the american policy
towards central america
it's a production
of the media process group some access
activists in chicago
and the program is called labor beat
[Music]
[Music]
we propose as a segment of public access
a labor access channel the worker of
chicago should be not only consumers but
producers of information
as the streets are a podium for free
speech the airwaves are a forum for
visual expression of our concerns as
people who shape and create our society
[Music]
what's the next phase of the war and
peace process in central america on
march 2nd 1988 noam chomsky professor of
linguistics and philosophy at mit spoke
on this question at the northwestern
university campus sponsored by the
evanston committee on central america
chomsky is the author of numerous books
and articles on international affairs
and is an expert on central american
politics
here are excerpts from that speech
what i wanted to do was focus attention
on the
coming phase of the
conflict
now well over a century old between the
united states and uh
essentially the population of central
america that's been an ongoing
war
an unequal war the victims are all over
there and there are many of them
it entered a new phase in the 1980s and
it entered another phase
beginning on february 3rd
change in the character of this war and
i do want to focus on this coming phase
february 3rd i pick because that was the
day in which the congress
responding to substantial
popular dissidents
imposed certain limits
on the
what the world court
called the unlawful use of force by the
united states in its attack against
nicaragua
i'll come back to the
background and details of that but let
me mention that february third is also
opens a new phase in another war that's
been going on at the same time
and that's a war between the
our government and
its population
now that's not unusual
typically states regard the general
population as an enemy that's normal
the task and role of the population is
to be apathetic obedient passive
if it's what's called a democracy
they're supposed to show up every once
in a while to ratify elite decisions but
if they get involved in anything beyond
that they're causing trouble and they
have to be controlled
and they're an enemy now among elite
groups there are variation there are
tactical variations and the reagan
administration happens to be at a rather
extreme end
of a spectrum but it is it's not the
spectrum hasn't changed it's the old
spectrum they just happen to be
extremists within that spectrum and
their fear and hostility of the general
population is also extreme
also they happen to be pretty open and
frank about it so they tell you if you
bother to listen
one of the first things that the reagan
administration did back in the early 80s
was to establish within the state
department a
thing called the institution called the
office for public diplomacy
which had the task of controlling public
debate
and discussion setting the framework for
discussion so it carried out
operations like what they called
operation truth which is one that orwell
would have loved and it had about as
much relation to truth as you would
expect something to have with that title
it was exposed all of this was exposed
more or less last summer
in the by one of the few reporters who
actually gave serious coverage to the
iran contra hearings by that i mean
didn't just pick up the release that was
handed out but actually bothered to look
up the documents alfonso charty of the
miami herald
back around july or august or so he
exposed the he did an a study of
documents that had been released about
the office for public diplomacy and he
went to members of the reagan
administration high administration
officials and asked them to explain
you know count for all of this and they
were quite frank and happy about it they
described the this
brainwashing operation
as one of their most spectacular
successes
and one which is correct if you think
about elite opinion
was very successful in setting the
discussion and debate about central
america and nicaragua in particular
in fact one high administration official
described
the these operations to charity as the
kind of operations you would carry out
in enemy territory
now that's a telling and accurate phrase
from the point of view the
administration the population is enemy
territory and the people are inhabitants
of enemy territory and you got if you
can't control them by force you got to
control them by propaganda now again
that's not a position that's unique to
this administration it's a standard
position uh i go into it later if you
like it's very it's long articulated in
our history back to the origins of the
of our society and it's very typical of
other societies as well
but the reagan administration is at an
extreme point
uh and they did they were very proud of
their successes in the war that they
conducted in enemy territory at home
that is the ideological war
uh now
uh if you can't control the if you can't
control the population by force and you
even and you can't even control it by
by propaganda the state is faces a
dilemma
and about only one thing they can do in
that case and that is to go underground
and in fact that's just what happened
during the 1980s
operation truth worked very well the
office of public diplomacy succeeded
very well
among elites who basically agreed with
the policies anyhow but it didn't work
very well among the general population
in fact it worked very badly the
population is more dissident and active
today than any time in the last
generation contrary to what you often
hear
there's not much articulation of this
because the elites don't reflect it and
congress is on a very weak reflection of
it the media virtually no reflection at
all but in the general population
there's plenty of activism and
dissidence and you can tell it and the
reagan administration learned it very
quickly they were very quickly driven
underground
they were driven underground by the
opposition the inhabitants of enemy
territory who were not going to tolerate
the actions that they intended to carry
out
now clandestine activities in any state
are a pretty fair measure of the level
of popular dissidence
open
violence open overt terrorism and
aggression are far more efficient than
clandestine terrorism they just work a
lot better
uh and furthermore they don't bear the
risk of exposure which sort of causes
all kind of problems when it
occasionally happens so when a state
turns to clandestine terrorism
clandestine violence it's because it's
forced to and it's forced through by its
own population clandestine activities
are not a secret from anybody else what
are called covered operations are
obviously not a secret to the victims uh
the kinds of operations that were in
there and also take say the operations
that were partially exposed during the
iran contra hearings plainly they
weren't a secret to the victims uh they
weren't a secret to the mercenary states
who were enlisted in the cause
they weren't a secret to shady
businessmen like
you know richard secord and the rest out
to make a buck in fact they weren't even
a secret to congress and the press if
you want to know the truth they were
just at a low low enough level so they
could be suppressed the only people that
they were secret from was enemy
population the enemy territory at home
there they were a secret the general
population didn't know about them
and that's the point of clandestine
operations clandestine operations are
always a in part a war against the
domestic enemy and when a state carries
out extensive clandestine operations
it's very much afraid of its domestic
enemy and that's what happened in the
1980s during the period august to
january august 87 to january 88
the
reagan administration congress and the
media
so
elites generally had a certain task
their task was to demolish the guatemala
city accords to which they were opposed
and
the accords were unacceptable to
washington therefore they had to go
well how do you do it
there were a number let me first notice
that there were a number of features of
the accords which were completely
unacceptable in washington the central
feature of the accords was what the
simultaneity feature you look at the way
the accords were structured they were
based on the idea that a number of
things have to happen simultaneously in
the various countries and so on now
that's unacceptable to the united states
for two reasons for one thing uh the
simultaneity requirement would place
barriers in the way of the united states
attack against nicaragua and that's
obviously unacceptable if the because
the united states intends to continue
the attack in one way or another
so that's out and on that there's an
elite consensus there's no debate over
this in the media or in congress with
very marginal exceptions the
simultaneous condition has to go the
accords must be interpreted so that they
apply to nicaragua and nicaragua alone
that's what that means and that was done
very effectively there have been a
number of studies of the media that give
the exact numbers but anybody's been
reading the papers or watching the tube
knows the story
the idea that there have to be a number
of things happening at once
is unacceptable because it would place
barriers to the u.s attack and since
that's unacceptable simultaneity
condition which is the core of the
accords has to go
there's another reason why the
simultaneity condition is unacceptable
it would place barriers on the u.s
attack against the populations of
guatemala el salvador and honduras
because the accords call for
measures to preserve liberty and
security and freedom and you know access
to free expression and so on and so
forth a whole range of measures which
are completely unacceptable to the
united states and cannot be possibly be
carried out unless without structural
changes in those countries that would
take that would eliminate the whole
security apparatus which was designed
with the support of the united states in
the case of
guatemala and honduras and developed and
imposed by the united states in the case
of el salvador designed precisely for
the purpose of preventing that to happen
that it was designed for the purpose of
traumatizing
repressing
torturing and killing if necessary the
domestic population
so that they won't cause any problems
anymore
those are the kinds of states where
you don't worry about propaganda you go
after the jugular if people start to
open their mouths
and that's what we did down there
and plainly those measures cannot be
stopped there's no way for the accords
to apply to the u.s terror states it's
inconceivable they have to undergo a
radical internal transformation
so therefore the simultaneity
requirement is unacceptable for that
reason alone now let me stress again
that there's an elite consensus on this
for example say take the matter of
freedom of the press
you'll notice that there has been no
debate in the united states no
discussion in the united states during
this phase of the accords on freedom of
the press say in el salvador in fact
what we hear is they already have
freedom of the press and in a certain
technical sense that's true that is
there's no law
in el salvador which says you can't have
an independent newspaper
you don't need a law there was an
independent press in el salvador
in 1980 when the united states moved in
to turn it into a
nazi-style terror state
there was a free press in fact there
were two independent newspapers not
leftists or anything like that
mainstream independent newspapers
well they're not around any longer in
the case of they were never censored
because we hate censorship in the case
of one of those newspapers
what happened is that the u.s run
security forces surrounded the office
with tanks
destroyed it
drove the editor out of the country with
assassination threats after several
assassination attempts that took care of
one of them in the case of the other one
the our security forces there are forces
remember our security forces picked up
the editor and another journalist in a
in a restaurant in san salvador took
them outside cut them to pieces with the
machete and left them in a ditch
somewhere the rest of them that took
care of the second newspaper so there's
no more problem of freedom of the press
in
el salvador and you'll notice that
nobody none of these sudden libertarians
who are so concerned about freedom of
the press have called for a reopening of
an independent press in el salvador
nobody ever heard the words la cronica
en el independiente
uh you hear about la prensa including
many lies but nobody hears about free
and of course nothing remotely like this
ever happened in nicaragua but uh you
never hear a word about freedom of the
press in
el salvador in fact these events that
i've these two newspapers to be precise
there were three references to what i've
just described in the entire 1980s in
the new york times so you can't claim
that we don't have a free press here but
it was so you know if you're really a
scholar and you've got a terrific memory
you can remember that something
unpleasant happened there but it's
certainly not an issue
we don't look into the question we don't
nobody calls for freedom of the press in
el salvador and for two very good
reasons
for one thing washington the office of
public diplomacy has ordered us that
that topic is off the agenda
we're not supposed to talk about that so
therefore being loyal cowards we
naturally obey so that's one reason
the other reason is that the call for a
free press in el salvador would be
ridiculous
you can't have a free press in el
salvador
without first dismantling the whole
terror system that the united states
installed precisely to ensure that you
can't have things like a free press or
for that matter bible study groups that
might turn into peasant self-help groups
and in fact all the developments that
caused washington to unleash the terror
apparatus so since it's absurd to ask
for a pre-press i guess there's no point
in doing so in any event no one asks
about it
meanwhile i should say in nicaragua
nothing remotely comparable has happened
the opposition claims harassment and of
course it always hits the front pages of
the newspapers but they're not expecting
to be
murdered or tortured and this opposition
is extreme it's the kind of opposition
which has never survived in a western
democracy in times of crisis
la prensa for example and the groups
around it
are openly support the u.s attack
against nicaragua nothing secret about
it i just had the
i guess i'm not sure it's happy
experience but experience of reading
three months worth of la prensa i must
be the only person outside the cia who
actually has all of la prensa since the
time was opened in my office at home
and it's just openly pro-contra doesn't
even hide it
it's simply a u.s government
disinformation or organ i mean to allow
the journal to publish it's as if in the
united states during the second world
war uh the media were largely dominated
by
japanese fascist journals calling for
the overthrow of the us government and
the liberation of you know
the territories in the pacific from the
racist murderers in the united states or
something like that i mean such things
are inconceivable you know never happen
in the west
and the same is true of what we call the
opposition which openly identifies with
the u.s attack against nicaragua and
regards the u.s as their only basic
political support
uh well that they they do get harassed
and you know they get censored and that
sort of thing they don't get murdered in
el salvador there's nothing even
remotely similar it's not like the press
knows all of this but will never report
any of it inconceivable if they report
these things though every journalist in
managua and san salvador knows it
but
again nobody is talking about the
application of the terms of the accords
which would permit the an opposition
even a mild opposition to function
nobody's talking about those conditions
in el salvador that's off the agenda and
in general all the simultaneity
requirements are unacceptable because
they would require the dismantling of
the terror apparatus that the united
states took such pains to impose and
still supports
now another feature of the accords
that's unacceptable was international
verification
the accords
had in them a provision for verification
an international verification commission
which included the five central american
countries the latin american democracies
the contadora countries the oas the
organization of american states and the
united nations well plainly that's
unacceptable essentially for the reasons
i just mentioned international
verification would put barriers in the
way of the us attack against nicaragua
and the u.s attack against the
populations of el salvador guatemala and
honduras
via the terrorist apparatus the military
regimes which were either imposed or
supported for that purpose so that's
unacceptable
another reason why international
verification is unacceptable to the
united states is that the latin american
countries though dependent of course on
the united states after all
we are the 800 pound guerrilla
they're dependent on the united states
and their limits beyond which they can
go nevertheless they have a degree of
independence they have a degree of
independence and therefore they're not
allowed in at all in fact nobody with a
degree of independence from the master
of the hemisphere is allowed in so
plainly international verification has
to go
and in fact the demolition job on the
accords was completed by january by
january the simultaneous condition was
thrown out
international verification was
terminated and in fact nothing remains
of the accords they are finished they
are part of ancient history nothing
remains of the guatemala city occurs the
press may talk about the ras accords and
so on but either they're lying
consciously or else they're
unwilling to bother to look
the fact of the matter is there is
nothing left of those accords what is
left
is a version of the accords written in
washington and transmitted by the press
and accepted by congress and that
version says nicaragua has to
accede to arbitrary demand stated by the
united states government whatever they
happen to be that's the accords
uh and that's all there is left there's
nothing left of the original text
well what were the
means used to destroy the accords this
is a very successful demolition job
what were the means used
well there were two kinds there were
military means and there were
ideological means you might say the
military means were first of all and
most important the intensification of
the cia supply flights
that was the most important event that
happened during august to
january as i mentioned the supply
flights which of course illegal to start
with
were sharply intensified to about two to
three a day
uh and uh also u.s surveillance flights
which we have a very extensive
surveillance apparatus all the fanciest
sr-71s and u-2s and satellites and spy
ships off the coast and so on are
carrying out intensive surveillance of
nicaragua and that was extended too now
both of those operations are significant
the supply flights are crucial in fact
critical because as is recognized on all
sides of this debate
the
contras the proxy army are not
guerrillas they have no remote relation
to guerrillas
the kgb doesn't fly two to three supply
flights a day into el salvador to keep
the gorillas in the field and nobody's
talking about sending humanitarian aid
to the guerrillas you don't have to
because they're part of the country
they're rooted in the country they fight
inside their own country they've got
their own network of support in fact the
reason for u.s terror in el salvador has
been to try to destroy that base of
support but they don't need supplies
they don't have to give but the
countries on the other hand have to get
everything from food to fancy
communication equipment to boots to arms
and so on because they're not part of
the country they're a foreign implant
that's what it means to say in fact you
re nobody nobody really denies this is
not a topic for debate you know the
reagan administration the first ones to
tell you that this force is going to
collapse unless we continue to provide
them with arms and supplies the meaning
of that which they don't bother to tell
you in the press but you can figure it
out the meaning of that is they're not
guerrillas because nobody does this for
gorillas and in fact that's written into
the accords it's under well understood
in central america you take a look at
the actual wording of the accords and
they say that and the indispensable
element
for
peace in the region is an end to any
form of support and they mention
military logistical propaganda or
whatever to two kinds of groups
namely irregular forces and
insurrectionist movements now the
distinction for that is that the
irregular forces of the contrast foreign
for foreign organized forces attacking
some country the insurrectionist
movement our movements or indigenous
guerrillas and the indispensable element
of the accords is the termination of any
form of support for them any form
logistical or whatever
and of course the as a corollary the use
of one country is a territory for
foreign insurrectionist movement for
irregular forces attacking another in
january the international commission the
verification commission gave published
its report now that was plainly the most
important thing that happened in january
here's this commission made up of the
five central american countries and the
latin american democracies and oas and
the u.n had investigated all the
countries they finally came out with a
report now we can finally get an
independent objective assessment of the
compliance with the
with the guatemala city accords well it
was mentioned in the new york times we
have a free press it got actually one
sentence in the new york times buried in
an article by james lemoyne in which he
stated uh that the conference that the
commission broke up in this agreement
well in fact its report was unanimously
accepted
but that was the total description in
the news report on january 14th when
15th the report was issued on the 14th
uh other here and there you could find
chicago tribune actually covered it in
this case but there was very little
coverage uh what and you can see why the
conclusions of the
commission were just not useful for
ideological warfare why well first of
all the commission denounced the united
states it singled out the united states
and the united states alone for
condemnation because the united states
had undermined the indispensable element
for peace in the region by continuing
its support for the irregular forces
attacking nicaragua from honduras
and in fact from costa rica and that
that's the central condemnation in the
accords well plainly that's useless
now the commission went on to say that
they couldn't provide detailed comments
on the particular countries of the
region and the reason for that was that
three countries objected el salvador
guatemala and honduras the three u.s
terror states would not permit
a description you can figure out for
yourselves what the description would
have been
uh and uh but the us wouldn't allow it
through its clients it blocked any
description of the
however they did carry out a pr have a
press conference in
costa rica and there the delegates
discussed this latin american
representatives spoke openly at the
press conferences of what they called
they said they were shocked by the
attitude of patent fear in the faces of
opposition people and trade unionists in
el salvador and guatemala the two u.s
terror states well playing there's no
point reporting that
the
commission also
praised nicaragua for what they called
concrete steps towards democratization
despite the ongoing us aggression well
it's plainly useless in fact none of
this is useful for ideological warfare
so therefore it didn't happen
and the reporting is virtually zero in
the new york times which is the most
important newspaper
worse than zero one sentence which was a
lie
the
commission plainly had to be disbanded
and the u.s simply insisted that it be
disbanded
the main u.s client in the region jose
napoleon duarte who is a democrat by
definition because he follows u.s orders
he's also one of the worst murderers in
the history of latin america and he's
reviled and detested throughout latin
america for this region but here he's
very highly praised
he uh said with some insight i think
that it wasn't really necessary to have
an international commission a
verification because he said the press
would suffice
for verification that's quite right that
provides that expresses a real insight
into the workings of the press uh well
that took care of the international
verification commission so one element
of the accords the basic element of the
accords is gone no more international
supervision
and
recognizing that the powerful make the
rules and the weak just obey
nicaraguan president ortega then
announced that nicaragua would adhere to
the conditions of the accords alone
a lot happened between the time of the
speech by noam chomsky on the 3rd march
1988 until about the 3rd of april when
this videotape was made
march 1st the conscious attack to
nicaraguan village
march 2nd the republican counteraid plan
was voted down the next day talks
between the nicaraguan government and
mosquito indians began by march 4 the
democratic counter-aid plan was voted
down two days later there was an
investigation of misuse of american
funds in el salvador march 9th
negotiations between the san anises and
the contras were counseled the next day
the contras released a captured american
the day after that the country has
agreed with talks with nicaragua
march 12th robert mcfarland pled guilty
to withholding counter information from
congress
on the 15th the senate voted to force
the president to inform them about
covert operations the next day the costa
rican president opposed contra aid then
the big four was indicted for a
conspiracy the u.s sent troops to the
honduran border saying the nicaragua had
invaded which nicaragua denied
the next day the troops did arrive from
the united states and the following day
oliver north resigned duarte in el
salvador almost lost control of the
national assembly the american troops
moved within 15 miles of nicaragua and
the nicaraguan country talks reconvened
on the 24th temporary truce between the
nicaraguans and the contours was ironed
out all the heavies pleaded not guilty
in the conjugate affair march 28
nicaragua freed the prisoners under the
cease-fire agreement and the next day
the negotiations began on the 30th
congress approved more contra aid april
1st the cease-fire began in nicaragua
the next day the u.s sent 1300 troops to
panama as of march 27th 25 000 people
have been killed in this
american-sponsored counter war against
nicaragua
and there's a very good article in the
propaganda review in the winter of 1988
that's the anatomy of the disinformation
campaign that illustrates very well noam
chomsky and edward herrmann's view of
the media and the way they manufacture
consent to certain conservative policies
what this article deals with is the way
that the mass media presented the
aftermath of an attempt to assassinate
the contra leader eden pastora that took
place on may the 31st of 1981. pastora
was a sandinista hero a hero of the
nicaraguan revolution who went to
nicaragua with the sandinistas after the
revolution and was a major figure in the
government he then left nicaragua
because he thought they were becoming
too closely involved with cuba and the
soviet union so eventually
pastora joined the contras and started
engaging in fights against the
nicaraguan government to try to
overthrow the sandinistas he got
completely fed up with the other contra
forces though that were directed with
the cia so on may the 31st of 1984 he
called a press conference to denounce
the other country leaders to separate
himself from them and to renounce his
contra activity at that press conference
a bomb went off that
wounded
many of the journalists there that
harmed pastora and some of his contra
friends in the kilt some other
journalists
right after that bomb went off abc and
pbs reported that the bomb was set off
by a basque eta terrorist who is working
for nicaragua the basques are a
mountain people in spain who want an
autonomous country free from spain and
from france and have been engaged
occasionally in armed struggle for
basque independence for many years
and
what happened was a disinformation
campaign was set up that was accusing
so-called basque terrorists of involving
themselves in terrorism in political
assassinations and violence
in central america as surrogates of the
nicaraguan
countries
the source for for this story was a
former member of the el salvador
liberation group who told the member of
a reagan group the office for public
diplomacy that the bosques were very
active in terrorist activities in
central america the office of public
diplomacy was a reagan administration
office that was the first state
propaganda bureau that the u.s
government ever had that is an agency to
create propaganda and disinformation for
a very specific policy which was that of
the reagan administration policy in
central america
so the office of public diplomacy put
out a report that they paid one of their
employees to publish that the basques
were very active in
terrorism in costa rica el salvador and
other
central american countries this had the
first effect of souring the
relationships between the costa rican
government and the sandinistas all sorts
of stories were leaked to costa rican
newspapers at the time the costa ricans
were trying to get better relations with
the sandinistas that the sandinistas had
sent terrorists to costa rica to carry
out political assassinations to
bomb um
people in the costa rican government in
the u.s embassy and the country forces
there and although there was no evidence
ever that basque were actually operative
there the stories were printed in costa
rica newspapers so after the pastora
attempt at his assassination the bombing
of pastora the office of public
diplomacy revealed documents about this
basque uh terrorist group and claimed
that one of their top terrorists were
there who was the one that was
attempting to
assassinate uh pastora and then he was a
sandinista yeah um
terrace and leaked this story out to the
media well abc and pbs
both
picked this story up they were dupes of
disinformation uh on june the first
abc on their world news rep
tonight reports boldly stated that there
is quote growing evidence that the
sandinistas have hired international
hitmen from a basque terrorist group
known as the eta to have pastora
killed they then went into the whole
details of the supposed basque terrorist
operations in
central america and said that all the
evidence points to this basque
hitman and presented this as a
sandinista plot which some people
thought might be a prelude to a u.s
invasion of san denis of nicaragua as
well as an attempt to create hostility
and tension between the costa rican and
the um
sandinisti
government now this is ironic because as
it came out later the guy that really
did the
assassination attempt of the pastora was
was related to the john hall
oliver north richard c cord
network it later came out that this
terrorist whose picture was at the news
conference a well-known international
terrorist
landed on john hall's ranch got
explosives from hall that were provided
by richard secord who's a top man in the
north network and that hall
gave him the explosives gave him the
false passport and press cadentials to
get into the press conference and then
helped him escape later this was this
came out in the christic institute's
lawsuit which uh began with the lapenca
bombing because one of the plaintiffs in
the christec
institute
suit was
tony avenon and martha honey who
tony was harmed in this bombing and so
he did research and pointed to john
hall's
[Music]
ranch so all the leads pointed to john
hall
chomsky talks about other ways in which
the
media simply lie about things for
instance he made a study of the
washington post and the new york times
for january february march of 1987. he
looked at all the editorials and found
they were all
anti-sandinista and he said
chomsky said there are two very striking
things about the san andreas government
compared to the other governments in
central america honduras guatemala and
el salvador one that signed an easter
government doesn't slaughter its own
population whereas the other three
honduras guatemala and el salvador have
killed over 150 000 of their own
citizens just in the 1980s
and second that's never pointed out by
the media is that
nicaragua was the only one of those
countries in which the government has
tried to direct services to the poor and
diverted resources for social reform and
education
he said well honduras is a little bit
different from guatemala and el salvador
they
don't kill so much but they just let the
rich rob the poor
so
it's also very interesting his analysis
in another propaganda review this winter
1987-88
chomsky says that
very interesting things happen in the
1920s
he talked about even in world war
one a bunch of american historians
offered themselves to president woodrow
wilson saying that they
wanted to do some historical engineering
so that they could get together and
engineer the facts of history so that
would serve the state
and in 1921 the famous american
journalist and pillar of the
establishment walter lipman said that
democracy can exist only if there is
manufacture of consent among the people
so you can see the problem democracies
have soviet union or totalitarian states
they say by god this is it and we have
state censorship but you can't quite
work with such a heavy hand in democracy
so what they have to do they have to
control what goes out and they have to
control what people think
so as chomsky said one of the ways to do
this is to create a debate so that it
looks like a lot of opinions are working
a lot of different information is coming
in but actually it's all working within
a very narrow margin very narrow
spectrum
all acceptable by the elites
nomskey is one of the great
intellectuals of our time and yet
see i saw him once on with an interview
with
the guy from pbs bill myers
two-part
interview
series with chomsky at the time that his
book
manufacturing consent came out
but he's hardly ever on the mainstream
media simply because he's such a radical
critic of them i might note that he's a
he's a very respectable professor at mit
he's one of the experts in the field of
linguistics he's one of the top
theorists of language and linguistic
activity in the whole country so he
basically has two academic careers as a
researcher and critic of american
foreign policy in the media and as a
specialist in the science of
linguistics where he's probably one of
the most respected theorists in the
entire world for that matter here's an
example of what the establishment does
to chomsky as well as not letting him on
tv
he's been forced to publish most of his
work with small circulation presses
because the big mainstream mass
circulation organizations won't
won't do it there they almost did once
back in the early seventies warner
modular publications which is a
subsidiary of warner communications
signed a contract with chomsky chomsky
and edward herrmann to write a book
called counter-revolutionary violence
blood baths in fact and in propaganda
well the manuscript was written and
accepted twenty thousand copies of the
book were printed there were ads put out
the new york review of books promotional
flyers were listed by it by the
publisher but
the parent company warner started
sniffing around
and
warner's william sarnoff
who was offended by the criticism of the
u.s government ordered the publication
not take place
well the president of the warner
subsidiary claude mccaleb protested this
and tried to work out a compromise so
that they could
do it but warner was interested only in
getting rid of the book and they not
only got rid of the book they got rid of
claude mccaleb the president of the
subsidiary then they did away with a
subsidiary usually they don't uh put
ideology over uh finances obviously they
lost a lot of money that they paid
chomsky in advance for the book they
printed twenty thousand dollar twenty
thousand uh copies so they must have
lost you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars but the book was such an
explosive indictment of u.s foreign
policy
that they just didn't want to publish it
south end press eventually published it
in two volumes i think it was called the
washington connection it basically is a
study of state terrorism sponsored by
the c.i.a the way that the cia has
supported state terrorism for instance
in indonesia
in the 1960s the cia engineered an
overthrow of the democratically elected
government and hundreds of thousands of
leftists were killed in indonesia
in this project sponsored by the cia
later in east timor
one of the indonesian
island chains
the indonesian government working with
the cia
carried out a bloodbath there of state
terrorism
that again the cia was involved in and
they went through vietnam they went
through central america all the ways
that the united states government
particularly the cia have supported
state terrorism this was just too
explosive a book for warners to publish
so they just covered it over the
incident created a big
furore in france that reported quite a
bit about it but not in the united
states this is blatant censorship there
that brings us to the end of another
alternative views
we'd like to thank some people who made
this production possible our cameraman
was eric eubank audio person kevin l
west and our assistant editor
christy swear
as usual we
are very grateful to austin community
television ac tv
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas 78713
we'll leave this little
sign up here on for a while so you can
jot it down
if you'd like to write to us
alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas
787
13.
goodbye
you